Good morning, Hank.
It's Monday, September 12th.
My posters have arrived!
So yesterday I took a walk in the woods with
Henry and the Yeti.
Henry and I practiced words.
John: Will you say tractor?
Henry: Tractor.
John: Can you say nerd?
Henry: Nerd.
John: Fighter?
Henry: [mumbles]
John: Pretty good.
Can you say happy?
Henry: Happy!
So we walked down to the white river and for
the longest time Henry just stood there and
watched the water flow downstream.
I think he was trying to figure it out.
Like, what is this made out of?
What does it do?
Why does it always go in the same direction?
Anyway, we stayed down there for a long time
and then we went to a playground.
For me, September 11th is always a good day
to spend with family because I am always reminded
on that day that we're only here for a little
while.
That we only have so long to play in the dirt
and ask questions of rivers.
Hank, it seems to me that one of the points
of being alive is that we get to pay attention.
We get to both participate in and observe
this weird universe that is simultaneously,
like, stunningly elegant and completely heartless.
Clone: Just like all your ex-girlfriends.
Oh come on, you can't just like zoom in, make
a joke and vroom out.
That's rude, okay?
I am trying to make a moving point here, this
is not a jokey-joke video.
Go back to signing!
So Hank, some nerdfighters were put off by
your video on Friday.
They felt like you didn't talk about 9/11
directly enough, or with enough seriousness.
I definitely found your video much less offensive
than say, Budweiser's 9/11 commercials, but
there was something weird about it, and yesterday
while I was walking in the woods with Henry
and the Yeti, I kept thinking about it.
And eventually I started thinking about maps.
Like if you want to render the planet in two
dimensions, you are forced to distort it.
You have to pick north is up, or north is
down.
You have to squeeze the continents this way,
or this way, or this way.
All year long we've been talking about how
the truth resists simplicity.
Hank, I agree with everything you said about
memory and 9/11 and terror, but like any map
it was distorted and insufficient.
So was my map last week about the Great Gatsby,
but the 9/11 map is much more, like, emotionally
and psychologically charged.
But Hank, I want to make something clear to
you and to Nerdfighteria.
The maps that we make with our vlogbrothers
videos will always be distorted and insufficient,
but the great thing about Nerdfighteria is
that Hank and I are not the only nerdfighters.
There are thousands of us working together
to build the best, most accurate maps we can
collectively draw.
What's interesting and important about online
communities in general, and Nerdfighteria
in particular, is that this community works
to improve and enhance our maps through youtube
comments and on twitter and on tumblr and
at the ning and in Your Pants when they aren't
hacked, which, unfortunately they still are,
sorry about that.
We're working on it.
And ideally together as a community we end
up making better maps than any of us could
make alone.
We call each other to pay attention.
In short, Nerdfighteria, we're in the business
of reminding each other to be awesome, and
I would argue that business is good.
Hank, I will see-- Wait!
I forgot about North Carolina!
Mom's going to kill me if I don't mention
North Carolina.
Hank, next month I will be speaking and signing
in Ashville, North Carolina as a fundraiser
for my parents' hometown library.
All the proceeds will go to the library.
Tickets are ten bucks, there's more info in
the dooblydoo.
Okay, Hank.
Now, I will see you on Wednesday.